la marsh how do you say that in french
maurice la marsh i threw my voice people
don't know this i'm the world's greatest
ventriloquist well speaking of which i
don't think even the people in the
control room uh know who maurice is do
you know kyle do you know who maurice is
have you figured it out yet connor yes
you do yes you do i bet you i bet you
caroline do you know who maurice is he's
googling me and he's spelling my name
wrong too no don't go go do you know who
he is no
okay all right so um just follow your
nose and you'll find out follow your
nose it always knows kellogg's froot
loop cereal with natural orange lemon
and cherry flavors so he's the toucan
from uh from fruit loops wow although i
just recently was replaced so yeah but
37 years on a job pretty good at what
point do they say you know we need a new
two i defend 37 years apparently like
what is it about your voice where you
want to knew to did it they wanted a
younger changeover can they tell do your
like do the toucan one more time and
let's see if we can tell his age
hello boys let's go to glitter island
first of all just the idea that he's
inviting his nephews to glitter island
wait does he might have been what got me
replaced what did he actually yes yes
but his glitter is what is what goes on
the froot loops it's like sure no that's
not how we're taking it i know if the
fruit loops are inviting
you could have got me canceled glitter
island glitter island what's in glitter
island
i don't know things to put on the on the
ceiling
yummy i'm on board no no well wait i
don't work for them anymore so sure i
can make these yeah it's not like you're
going to get cancelled from that's what
you're being called as island what it's
what epstein called his island right
jeffrey epstein did he really yeah he
was known as the big fruit loop holy
moly i did not know this is like a
commercial from eight years ago
oh you're lying
well you're you're prevaricating you're
yes you want to hear some more voices
that you might know did he say
prevaricate i don't do uh no no i know
okay
go ahead do this and kyle tell me who
this is pinky are you pondering what i'm
pondering
yes we shall take over the world come
back to the lab to plan for tomorrow
night
the brain brain
yes correct well you get well you said
it you said pinky so how would it be it
couldn't be just a forfeit it could be
pink eye i could be talking to somebody
with pink kyle see if you get this one
do uh uh peter falk
really
okay well the reason he's asking him to
do that he's also one of the best
impressionists but he's got a lot of
cards can you say i'm sorry to bother
you but do you know where i get a pair
of shoes that look like that for about
twenty five dollars i'm on a cop salary
does anybody at the control room know
who pierre falcon
you might
caroline do you know who peter falk is
another generation she's born in 1996 oh
that's a no that's how she says no
that's how the kids say you might you
know what you might remember him from
just this line because this is a classic
movie that's like entering its 25th
anniversary everybody's seeing it again
and princess buttercup
kissed him with a perfect kiss
as you wish there that princess bride
from the princess bride who's the
grandfather of the princess
well them with this one tony curtis no
no no let's stay in this decade yeah do
you realize that most of your
impressions as as uh you for you i'm in
i'm in that place i'm in that place in
life where everybody i do
nobody under the age of 45 has heard of
them which is actually a great thing as
a cartoon voiceover artist because i
have reused so many
of these people
on disenchantment on futurama who are
you in futurama i'm uh lissio i'm morbo
the newscaster and lieutenant kif
croaker oh sir the rest of the crew
doesn't share your passion for velour
and i'm also calculon the star of all my
circuits and i'm the dawnbot and i'm
clamps clamp pamper
chicken lawyer and i know when i'm
fingerling
and i'm also he doesn't bother myself
let's go to glitter island with you can
sam
jeremy's fainting jeremy is our editor
he's
don't know any voices because you don't
put headphones on no no
i don't know maurice's voices because i
don't care about maurice
[Music]
you